you guys uh there's a whiz and yourself
i feel like all kind of
will be kind of somewhat tied together
yeah forever yeah just based on and
currency obviously but just based on the
smokers club on
obviously the the records early on in um
cushion on cushion orange juice and
glass house and all that like
i feel like
this is a kind of a nostalgic project
for for guys like myself who missed that
era of hip-hop what we like to call
maybe the early blog era yes yeah early
blog era
um
what like i guess for you
what was your thought process and saying
like
yeah this is this feels right because
you know wiz has got a lot going on you
got a lot going on
this is doing a whole lot of [ __ ] he's
doing weed he's doing podcasts albums
everything um
i heard that
you guys did this in one day yeah one
session yeah i mean
everybody else had solo records with
girl talk before that i'm sure and that
gave us the opportunity to have our own
and like individual songs but i think
man it was for me it was a breath of
fresh air it was the kind of album where
not only did we not expect to do it and
we just [ __ ] got into like oh this
[ __ ] is gonna come out crazy but
not having the pressure of it thinking
about it like it's
a label album kind of thing or all you
got to be very calculated we was like
[ __ ] making jam and ass music
and then put it together and it's out
now you know um and for me i i needed
this opportunity with the homies too
because it just reminds me of why i even
do it and when i started and the feel of
that um and we as being the first person
i even went on tour with you know back
in 2010 so i was like man we it's a
different kind of you know family
friendship especially in this music
industry that bro we we came together
mates with jam [ __ ] lily just had fun
bro